museum curators in scotland discovered
an ancient Egyptian burial cloth
thousands of years old the full-length
Shroud shows the deceased as an Egyptian
god it was used to cover the mummified
body Jonathan Vigliotti is in London
with how this rare artifact was found
still in remarkable condition Jonathan
good morning good morning this piece of
ancient history was discovered in an old
crumpled up and torn paper bag it been
hidden away in the museum archives get
this during World War two and only
recently discovered it looks like
garbage just waiting to be tossed out
but after more than 70 years sitting on
a shelf in the National Museum of
Scotland storage a team of curious
curators finally peeked inside dr.
Margaret Maitland made the discovery
that highlight a 2000 year old mummy
shroud a type of linen cloth used to
wrap the mummified bodies of
high-ranking Egyptians dr. Maitland
shroud was so fragile it took 24 hours
of humidifying to unwrap each fold that
we was just so exciting Maitland says
the final result was so well preserved
they could even read the name of the
deceased as I am command as it turns out
the museum already had relics of his
well studied parents his father a
high-ranking Egyptian official malsu f
and his mother tenuity mother and father
were put on display while son for some
reason was overlooked man went into
storage
but now decades later this ancient
family tree pieced back together these
incredible objects and the shroud
officially goes on display today the
museum still has over
eleven million pieces from all over the
world in storage so who knows what other
treasures are waiting to be discovered
yeah all right John I think thank you
expert what's gonna say I had Malik's in
staffing at the table because he majored
in what well for one year I was a
geology major my high radical costo what
do you make of this story
yes don't throw away the paper bag also
Indiana Jones that last scene when the
Ark of the Covenant is shuttled away you
never know what's in those museum
warehouses treasures their own
collection their own collection right
now we're gonna throw away a crumpled up
paper bag you would have opened it up I
get it you never know where you might
find us right that's right